je vais vous partager quelque chose
j'étais peut-être dans votre classe et
vous n'avez pas remarqué
lorsque je suis arrivée à la fac de
droit et j'ai entendu parler d'un
concours de plaidoirie
fidèle à ma timidité
je ne me suis pas inscrite
la deuxième année droite dans mes bottes
je ne me suis pas inscrite non plus
mais un ami a inscrit pour moi mon nom
sur la liste des participants
je me suis présenté
j'ai passé le premier tour le deuxième
tour le troisième tour jusqu'à me
retrouver en finale au palais de justice
de Paris
c'était une soirée extraordinaire
ce soir là sous les lustres scintillants
toute ma famille et mes amis étaient
présents
là un membre du jury m'a dit cette
fameuse phrase
madame
vous avez la parole
ce soir là
je me suis levé
et j'ai gagné le concours de plaidoirie
cela m'a fait prendre conscience d'une
part que j'avais une voix et que cette
voix pouvait compter d'autre part que si
j'avais dû attendre d'atteindre les
études supérieures pour avoir accès à ce
cadre d'expression c'est bien qu'il
m'avait manqué en amont notamment à
l'école
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
réfléchi à une solution nouvelle mais je
me suis d'abord rappelé quelque chose
en fait j'avais à ce moment-là
l'impression d'être comme une jeune
super héroïne qui découvre son super
pouvoir à cette période de ma vie j'ai
commencé à prendre davantage la parole
et j'ai perçu la puissance que cela
pouvait avoir
je me revois encore assise sur le coin
de mon lit un peu des étoiles dans les
yeux à me dire et maintenant que faire
et je me suis rappelé une chose c'est
que un super héros est rarement seul
il y avait peut-être d'autres personnes
comme moi
il fallait simplement que je les trouve
il fallait que je constitue mon équipe
d'Avengers
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai proposé à
des amis qui avaient connu comme moi une
expérience un peu similaire de prise de
parole de réfléchir à la construction
d'une solution positive
et l'association trouve ta voix est née
une association
colère et qui a pour mission de
permettre aux jeunes de révéler leur
potentiel par la prise de parole
nous avons imaginé un système dans
lequel un jeune bénévole
un étudiant une étudiante va aller
pendant plusieurs semaines dans l'école
pour accompagner un groupe classe dans
la révélation de son potentiel
du père à père
l'entraide d'un jeune à un autre jeune
avec cette idée derrière la prise de
parole de permettre à la jeunesse de se
rencontrer
de céder s'entraider et de grandir
ensemble
suite à cette période de formation des
événements de restitution sont organisés
pendant lesquels les jeunes prennent la
parole dans des lieux symboliques de
notre histoire collective
nous étions jeunes sans argent sans
réseau alors par où commencer
nous avions en commun d'avoir toutes et
tous participé et gagner des concours de
plaidoirie donc nous avions comme une
forme d'expertise mais ce que nous
avions surtout c'était une vision
une grande ambition
et une énergie inébranlable
pour réussir nous avions besoin d'un
allié et qui de mieux que l'éducation
nationale et son premier représentant le
professeur
nous avons donc envoyé des lettres à des
lycées publiques de Seine-Saint-Denis
trois mois plus tard
les premières formations trouvent à voir
se lancer dans trois lycées de Créteil
Pantin et Aubervilliers
un mois plus tard nous présentions
officiellement ce programme expérimental
de formation à la prise de parole lors
d'une grande soirée où les jeunes ont
pris la parole à l'Assemblée nationale
ce soir là
élève professeur formateur bénévole
toutes et tous ensemble nous avions
poussé les portes de l'Assemblée
nationale
ce soir là
nous avions fait un pas de plus vers
l'école de nos rêves
je ne sais pas comment vous dire mais
parfois quand vous avez une idée dans la
main dans l'esprit dans le cœur
vous savez qu'il n'y a aucune hésitation
je me suis toujours dit il ne faut pas
avoir peur de l'échec il faut avoir peur
de ne pas essayer
ça ne veut pas dire que tout sera facile
mais que ce sera possible
un chanteur Jacques Brel a dit quelque
chose comme
tenter essayez échouer même ce sera
votre réussite vous vous cassez la
gueule et ben vous vous cassez la gueule
leur repas de se casser la gueule
et pendant tous ces mois de travail ces
phrases m'ont suivies un peu comme un
mantra
si ça ne marche pas
et alors
mais des preuves de réussite m'ont aidé
à continuer
depuis 2017 l'équipe d'Avengers a grandi
nous sommes passés de 3 à 30 lycée
partenaires l'équipe de l'association
s'est étoffé avec l'arrivée de salariés
et nous formons désormais 20 jeunes
parents à la prise de parole
en 2019 il s'est passé quelque chose de
très important pour nous
le grand oral du bac a été instauré
le grand oral c'est une nouvelle épreuve
du baccalauréat coefficient 10
cela veut dire très concrètement que
désormais chaque jeune de France
devra passer une épreuve de prise de
parole qui aura un impact fondamental
sur la suite de son avenir professionnel
il est important de préciser que ce que
nous recherchons ce n'est pas forcément
une prise de parole éloquente parfois la
prise de parole est reliée à cette
notion d'éloquence qui a une prise de
parole très théâtrale et très
performative
nous écartons cette vision pour lui
préférer une prise de parole plus
personnelle
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que chaque
jeune accompagné par l'association
puisse oraliser un message personnel au
quotidien de manière structurée et
convaincante dans le respect de la
diversité des voix des parcours et des
caractères
tout cela ne serait pas possible sans la
création d'un cadre de bienveillance car
au-delà de la prise de parole ce que
nous souhaitons c'est de permettre à
chaque jeune de prendre confiance en lui
nous créons donc ces espaces d'accueil
de la parole des jeunes une sorte de
bulle de confiance au sein de laquelle
les jeunes vont oraliser parfois pour la
première fois ce qu'ils ont sur le cœur
et ce que nous pouvons entendre et
frappant
laissez-moi vous faire un nuage de mots
harcèlement scolaire
guerre
anxiété climatique
mais aussi
espoir rêve action engagement
maman
je t'aime
tous ces mots ont été prononcés au
Panthéon
là où le président de la République
parle et où désormais à Nice
nightsha Antoine
parle aussi
nous nous sommes rendus compte que nous
ne montrons pas seulement par l'exemple
qu'enseigner la prise de parole à
l'école et non seulement possible mais
souhaitable
nous montrons aussi que cela crée des
espaces d'expression au sein duquel les
jeunes peuvent s'exprimer s'écouter
cela a un impact très concret sur les
élèves
en réalité il découvre une forme
d'étincelle à l'intérieur de qui leur
permet de voir l'école un peu
différemment et de revenir dans la salle
de classe avec enthousiasme
l'enthousiasme d'apprendre quelque chose
de nouveau
l'enthousiasme de s'exprimer
et les professeurs perçoivent cette
évolution chez leurs élèves ils
observent même des changements dans la
dynamique de leur cours en réalité la
création de ces espaces de parole à
l'école
améliore le climat scolaire
aujourd'hui nous travaillons en main
dans la main avec l'Éducation nationale
et cela nous donne l'envie d'aller
encore plus loin en réalité nous
participons à un changement systémique à
la transformation du modèle éducatif
vers plus d'oralité et ce changement
pourrait avoir des impacts sur des
milliers de jeunes et ceux sur des
générations
imaginez-vous
mesdames et messieurs
quelle société aurions-nous
si en France dès l'enfance nous étions
habitués à nous parler
à nous exprimer
depuis le début je vous parle de
super-héros et d'Avengers mais mais en
réalité il n'y a aucun super héros
ni chez les élèves ni chez les
professeurs ni dans l'association
personne n'a à faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire pour avoir le droit à
la parole
tout le monde doit pouvoir posséder et
se saisir de ce droit
quel qu'il soit et où qu'il soit
chacun doit pouvoir être écouté dans le
respect de la diversité des personnes
des personnalités et des parcours
prendre la parole
c'est prendre le pouvoir
merci
[Applaudissements]